what do you do if a kid is in danger
sometimes shouting at them is enough but
what if the kid is really in danger as
in just within pouncing distance of a
very hungry tiger danger you might keep
the kid quiet wait for the coast to
clear and then when it's safe
explained the danger that might seem
like the obvious answer but in nature
very few animals are capable of holding
it all in this ability to wait and
communicate information after an event
has passed or about an event that will
happen in the future
it's called displaced reference humans
do it honeybees do it and now it turns
out that orangutans do it too
researchers conducted an experiment with
seven female orangutan the Kitab a
jungle of North East Sumatra they
pretended to be predators by draping
themselves with giant sheets and
crawling along the forest floor one
sheet was covered in a tiger striped
pattern one had a pattern of abstract
colors one was white with multi-coloured
spots and the last was a plain white
sheet once the predator was spotted by
an orangutan the researcher would stop
for two minutes before moving out of
sight surprisingly the orangutans would
wait several minutes before letting out
a warning call they did this in 12 of
the 24 trials with an average delay of
seven minutes
so why the wait Sumatran orangutans have
the longest child-rearing period of any
primate Infini Wregget and stay with
their mothers for up to nine years which
allows them to develop critical force
survival skills letting out a warning
call at the first sight of a predator is
just too dangerous because it might
alert the predator to their presence but
at the same time the parent needs to
teach the infant to recognize these
situations in the future so the mothers
wait long enough that the danger has
passed but short enough that the infant
can still learn from the encounter
researchers say this clearly
demonstrates the ability to use
displaced reference and a non-human
primate something never seen before in
the wild and that suggests another way
that orangutan is one of our closest
living relatives and a prolific
communicator may be a model for how
language evolved in people who knows if
we gave a ring at hands a million years
they just might have something to say
[Music]
you
[Music]